[Music]
I've been waiting 40 years for this they
called themselves Ghostbusters according
to these hacks they saved the world no
eyewitnesses and who is found to carry
the torch descendants of Egon Spangler
you have a minor hanging out the side of
a moving vehicle firing a laser gun
indiscriminately has a proton back it's
completely safe I wouldn't say
completely safe the Ghostbusters are
finished right well overruled
sustained thank
you you the weird guy who buy strange
old things correct on both counts buddy
you just hit the
jackpot what is it better question is
what's inside of
it the parable tell of an unimaginable
evil commanding an army of
ghosts that's the power to kill by fear
itself like literally scared to
[Music]
death we might be looking at our second
Ice
Age we're going to need all the help we
can get let's get to
work can I be of any help melet in
uniform
yeah if there's something strange
if there's something weird what are
people going to call Ghostbusters what
do you
[Music]
want where the Ghostbusters can I tell
you something else what Buster makes me
feel good makes me feel
good heads up all dark and horny at
12:00
[Music]
yeah